it's the cuomo's
[Music]
starring andrew and chris
cool
[Music]
let's check in with the two brothers who
love blaming others
so what did chris cuomo say before
november he hopes that you don't
remember
looks like back up cuomo brother chris
suffered some memory loss after his
bravely televised battle with corona
on tuesday while talking about january 6
he claimed he never defended black lives
matter
rioters back in the day yeah i'm six
foot four
[Laughter]
i'm 5 10 but anyway fortunately for
chris
cnn viewers all six of them have short
memories because the tape tells a
different story
around 140 officers assaulted some very
badly
this is the truth period
it is no less the truth because black
lives matter supporters
committed acts of violence too
even if you want to believe that the
media was okay with what they did
which sure as hell isn't true on this
show and please show me where it says
that protests are supposed to be polite
and peaceful he's adorable
you might want to double that dose of
ginkgo biloba
and no we're not done with you yet chris
last night uh he defended critical race
theory calling out conservatives for
blowing it
out of proportion the critical race
theory
this boogie man is just the new front on
the culture war
that's all the brown menace is gone you
have to they're not coming over the wall
to come and take your women
now it's they're coming to take your
kids
now what critical race theory is really
about is just choosing
which stories matter in the teaching of
the history of america
yeah that's what it is you didn't even
read about it
you were you were criticizing people who
actually did their homework
you didn't even do the homework so crt
is the boogie man
dude i could have sworn that was your
brother the alleged
the alleged butt grabber continues to
laugh all the way to the bank
and in the face of covet victims this is
him commiserating with his fellow
governors yesterday
very few people were going through what
we went through
and we went through it together and
speaking for myself
it was a tremendous personal benefit
does this guy even realize what's coming
out of his mouth
tremendous personal benefit sure 15 000
nursing home residents died under your
watch but who's counting
remember he scored a 5.1 million dollar
book deal
hyping up his heroic response to the
pandemic still it sold fewer copies than
michael moore's guide to tantric sex
by the way you still have my copy brian
you moved your office i didn't know
where to drop it it's actually
it's actually a fold-out yeah it has to
be
or is it a fold-in or is it just folds
maybe it's just folds what am i doing uh
joe uh what do you make of the governor
are we taking the governor out of
context no
uh but he's got to keep his mouth shut
right now
pending proceedings in the in the court
of law he
he might take the fifth amendment before
he says anything because
uh that's the smart play yeah they
defended him so much in mainstream media
they talked about how
women were attracted to him when they
should have been looking into the
nursing home numbers
yeah and once they say that he was good
they can't
tell us now that he was bad so they'll
just memory haul it yep he's doing the
best thing possible just keep quiet
yeah that's true that's true you know uh
cat he proves governor cuomo proves that
if you have an industry on your side
like the media
you just outlast the scandals yeah
absolutely and he said
the other day when he was like oh we're
going to do with gun violence what we
did with kovid like what you're going to
put the shooters in the nursing homes
and then lie about it write a book and
make millions of dollars what do you
mean by that i just can't imagine how
he can still go out there and he really
does see himself as a hero
he really does think that people think
that about him rather he doesn't realize
how horrible he really is yeah you know
i'm gonna
pose a thoughtful question to you not
the usual kind
because you're a vet uh veteran of fox i
always get when chris cuomo is talking
or doing his commentary he's not
actually speaking to the viewers
he's speaking to his peer group right
it's like
no one really cares about the things
that like the viewer doesn't
doesn't care about his personal feelings
about stuff he's doing that to
to like talk to the people in the media
world whereas when we're talking we're
talking to the viewers
because we appreciate our viewers and
because of course we have them
right uh and he he believes that his
viewers are and he's right new york
washington in los angeles and that's why
people have this uh
this uh inadequate or and um unmatched
understanding of they think he is much
more popular than he actually is because
they don't travel
they have no idea most people if you
travel to the place where we go like
it's on our book tours where
people know who you are they don't even
watch cnn they don't even know what cnn
stands for
but in cuomo's situation in particular
you mentioned i'm a veteran in
all the years covering all these stories
uh the small and big
i've never seen someone so ridden in
scandal get such a pass
this guy should be humiliated somewhere
living on a farm in schenectady
instead he continued not only he passed
the last time they had a meeting with
governors
he was so written in scandal they had to
have a republican fill in for him
this time he actually did it himself and
made that statement
he killed 50 000 50 000 people died on
his watch 15
000 in nursing homes 10 separate women
accused him of sexual harassment
then he used his power to get donors and
family members
test when no one else had them any one
of those would have destroyed anyone
forever remember gary hart met a woman
on an island
right and he was destroyed how this guy
still has a job
and is running for reelection i've never
seen anything like it yeah he truly is
the brian kill meet of governors
that is not uh that is not an apt
analogy
how dare you i gave a i helped your show
and you just hurt my career i mean what
is wrong with you
there's a lot wrong with you could have
said that to any of these great
there is a lot wrong with me i i tried
to give some substance
i don't know why because i was just
listening to you when i'm going you
weren't even paying attention yeah i
i was hey i always do uh dagon it is
like the media hates
what we do because it's not for them
but when you look at what they're doing
it's always for the media that's my
point i was trying to make to brian in
which he
went off on some weird tangent about
well i
metric sex well the members of the media
who pay attention
to these two yeah are jealous simply
because
they want the path to be as easy as it
was
for these two pantmans
they that they would not they would not
be
anywhere if not for daddy you know andy
cuomo would be selling catheters
door-to-door
and don't knock it and by the way and or
not chris cuomo
couldn't even get cast as fredo in a
neighborhood playhouse
of version of the godfather but lo and
behold
they're doing this kind of like pose-off
flex-off with each other
to figure out who's the biggest liar on
the planet
well i'm afraid oh we're out of time
up next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else